under the supervision of the US military
Syrian Kurdish YPG fighters fill in
tunnels and defensive positions along
the border with Turkey the YPG forms the
bulk of the u.s. trained and backed
Syrian defense force the SDF it will now
pull back between five and 17 kilometers
although turkey is demanding a 30
kilometer buffer kilometer is a large
number and would cut us off from an
important road that leads to Aleppo
it is impossible the administration
would accept this because of the impact
on our daily lives
Kurdish administered northeastern Syria
has been relatively peaceful after YPG
fighters pushed out ISIL earlier in the
war the u.s. considers the Kurds their
most important partner in the fight
against ISIL but turkey says the YPG is
allied to the Kurdistan Workers Party
the PKK so it's long term presence along
the border won't be tolerated the PKK
which was formed in Turkey 41 years ago
is considered a terrorist group by
Ankara the EU and the US if the fighters
withdraw from the border area it will
hurt us
they're the only force that stops
corruption in the region the United
States has interests with Turkey as well
as the Kurds we also know that the Kurds
are the only ones who successfully stood
against ISIL so it's in America's
interest to keep them on site the
withdrawal deal was reached after turkey
repeatedly warned it would send its
military into northern Syria to target
the YPG Plaza millet image we want our
people to live safely we know we are
strong combat units and we can fight but
we fear for our people but now with this
agreement we can build a good life in
our regions and cities the areas the
Kurds have withdrawn from Arthur now
being monitored from the Turkish side
president regi type Iran says turkey
will launch its own operation to
establish a safe zone if talks with the
u.s. failed to give Turkish troops full
control of the area within a few weeks
and while there is a joint u.s. a
Turkish command center there's still no
agreement on the size of the zone
or its command structure Vernon Smith
al-jazeera
antakya